[Music]
in tonight's whatever happened to
segments we check in with a small Texas
town devastated by a tragedy five years
ago as correspondent Casey steagle tells
us tonight there are still many
unanswered questions
[Music]
six times a day the train rolls through
West Texas the same tracks which once
carried supplies to the town's
fertilizer plant 124 mrs. joy over 200
damaged hundreds of people injured 15
keel the West's mayor Tommy Muscat and
750 ones when the explosion happened and
literally 75 feet from here 12 of the 15
who died were first responders trying to
put out a fire at West fertilizer
company as they worked a chemical inside
the plant
ammonium nitrate ignited in the distance
the high school it was destroyed and has
since been rebuilt you can see its
proximity to the fertilizer plant I'm
standing in what was once the crater
made by the blast ten feet deep 95 feet
wide this case is far from cold it's
being worked on every day the three
years after the explosion the Bureau of
Alcohol Tobacco and Firearms announced
the initial fire at the plant that night
was intentionally set still no arrests
even after extensive research recreating
the entire scene at its special fire
research lab so if you can imagine all
the possible causes of this fire every
one of those was tested and retested
Texas has since passed legislation
regulating storage and reporting of
dangerous substances like ammonium
nitrate nothing has changed on a federal
level I'm passionate about this town
probably to a fault
Musca doesn't want other communities in
danger as he still works to heal his own
most of the homes have been rebuilt the
nursing home even the town park but
getting here wasn't easy we've come back
father in West Texas
Casey steagle Fox News